today we're doing a new experiment new
for us
holy crap I got it
the reaction of sodium with water is
terribly well-known we've done it lots
of times on our videos you drop a piece
of sodium into water and because sodium
is lighter than water it skitters around
on the surface and reacting liberating
hydrogen and then sometimes the hydrogen
catches fire and in one of our videos
exploded - the orange sodium grain and a
piece of it hit the camera which on your
camera oh it is - this time we want to
react a small amount of water with an
excess of sodium and the way we've done
it is to take a piece of sodium and put
it in the bottom of the beaker and then
drop drops of water from quite high up
onto the block of sodium so one drop
after another
you
so what happened was that the first few
drops hit the surface and because it's
hard probably ran partly off and
reaction started round the bottom of the
lamp of sodium and you can see bubbles
and the bubbles are probably hydrogen
coming off because the reaction of water
with sodium gives sodium hydroxide and
hydrogen since there isn't very much
water there'll be a strong solution of
sodium hydroxide and that's unlikely to
boiled because the alternative
explanation that these are bubbles of
steam and then because the reaction
produces heat it appears that the sodium
melted but because it's quite a small
piece it just stayed as a glob of liquid
sitting on the bottom the beaker then
when the last drop came down it very
conveniently hit the surface of the
sodium moreless square holy crap I got
it and because water is quite dense it
made a crater as it were a puddle where
it's hit the sodium and then because the
water is denser than sodium it's settled
inside the liquid sodium imagine you
have liquid sodium the melting point is
96 degrees Celsius or centigrade however
you like to say it and which is very
close to the boiling point of water and
of course it could have been hotter than
96 degrees so when the water goes in it
may well be in an environment that is
higher than its boiling point but
because the water is denser and has
momentum it will go down to the bottom
so it's completely surrounded by hot
sodium and the reaction starts and if
you look carefully first of all the
reaction blows upwards presumably going
through the hole
all that the waters made going in and
you could see an orange color which is
probably the color of hot sodium vapor a
few frames later on the reaction really
gets going and the pressure of gas
probably hydrogen blows the whole thing
apart because there's much less water
than sodium the liquid that comes out
must be not completely but a large
amount of it will be tiny droplets of
metallic sodium and as these droplets go
through the air some of them will react
with the water vapor in the air and some
will react with the oxygen in the air
and there's a lot more oxygen than water
and you can see there one or two pieces
that come off in this direction that are
glowing really very hot and orange it
just demonstrates that when you do an
experiment in a new way
you see even quite a common reaction in
a completely new light of course to
understand precisely what's going on
you'd have to do lots of different
experiments varying the amount of water
varying the temperature of the sodium
perhaps even putting a thermocouple into
the sodium to measure the temperature
but doesn't really matter what does
matters you can see that even this
reaction is more exciting than we
thought as you know sodium is only the
second of the alkali metals as you go
down the group and we were lucky enough
when we were using the high-speed camera
to also video potassium rubidium and
cesium and in the next few weeks you'll
be able to see all of those and some of
those were even more exciting than
sodium